families and friends good afternoon and
welcome to convocation for ma candidates
in the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences I thank all of you for coming
to celebrate the accomplishments of our
masters candidates we honor today a
superb group that on commencement this
coming Wednesday will join the ranks of
our close to 38,000 graduate alumni and
will embark on doctoral programs or will
begin professional careers around the
world we honor today also the families
and friends of our candidates who have
been alongside them during the one or
two-year sprint leading to the MA I
would ask all ma candidates to rise and
upload those family members and friends
who have helped them to be here today
today an outstanding master's candidate
and distinguished masters alumnus will
address the assembly in turn the MA
candidates remarks will be offered by
mr. James mcgee in the quantitative
methods in the social sciences program
mr. McGee received in 2004 the
certificate in international business
from the SC Johnson graduate school of
management and the BS in 2005 in policy
analysis and management from the College
of human ecology both at Cornell
University with concentrations in
healthcare policy Social Welfare social
welfare policy and social inequality mr.
McGee was on the dean's list at Cornell
from 2002 through 2005 he has
co-authored a number of articles
including what do we know about the
Chinese self illustrations with
self-esteem self-efficacy and self
enhancement with fsy Kwan and CM hui in
the Oxford Handbook of Chinese
psychology since 2010 mr. McGee
coordinated research and the management
division in the Columbia Business School
and has served as a teaching assistant
for several courses in leadership and
management at Cornell's department of
psychology and columbia business school
mr. McGee
greetings fellow Colombians Thank You
Nina Lonzo for this wonderful
opportunity to address the graduating
class of 2012 this is a special day for
many reasons at least as many as there
are students sitting in front of this
stage it is also a special day because
for Americans it is Mother's Day I am
very fortunate to have my mom as well as
my dad and brother here to support me
today this morning for Mother's Day I
gave my mom a muffin I think that this
is a wholly appropriate gift not to
mention cost effective because if I had
to sum up how I got here today it would
have a lot to do with my mom and with
muffins you see I'm not the first in my
family to graduate from Columbia my mom
earned her master's degree from teachers
college here not long ago but that's not
the reason why I came to Columbia to
understand that I have to look further
back in time back to when I developed a
passion for lifelong learning a passion
for spending my days in classrooms and
laboratories with people like you I'm
not certain why I've grown to love
learning as much as I do and why
finishing a degree program is a little
more sad than joyous for me but I can
make a pretty good guess and it has to
do with muffins when I was in
kindergarten and elementary school my
mom and dad were concerned that my
schooling was not providing me with
enough intellectual stimulation so in
the mornings and on weekends my mom and
I would take a short trip in our
Oldsmobile to the muffin corner a little
coffee shop in my hometown there we
would order a muffin and orange juice
for me and a coffee for my mom and then
the work would begin my mom would pull
out from her bag a selection of little
yellow workbooks covering topics like
spelling grammar and mathematics we
would work together on these books
drinking our orange juice and coffee
although it was sometimes very hard work
for my little
garden brain I deeply enjoyed these
times by combining lessons with one of
my other favorite things food I grew to
love each new subject learning new
concepts wasn't associated with stress
and pressure but rather with love and
support and encouragement these muffin
lessons while clearly helpful in giving
me tools to use later in the classroom
taught me something even more important
to take ownership of my own education I
realize now that it would have been easy
for my parents to send me off to school
each day and expect the teachers and me
both to do our respective jobs somehow
they could have thought the information
would just diffuse down a gradient into
my brain but instead they went out of
their way to find new opportunities for
learning I grew to appreciate learning
both in and out of the classroom and
knowledge became its own sweet reward
able to be found everywhere I looked I
was able to look at my education in
unconventional ways and find its true
purpose for me understanding how the
world works around me in the hope of
making it a little better for a young
kid just beginning to understand how
much information there exists in this
world this made life glorious when I
came to Columbia in 2009 I hadn't
changed much since elementary school I
still wanted to take ownership of my
education and of this place if only in
some small way I knew that the best way
to do that was through research you see
research is to university level
instruction what my muffin lessons were
to my elementary school coursework a
path to get behind and beyond the
knowledge that I could learn from
textbooks and to generate new knowledge
and to share it with others I also knew
that the master's program in
quantitative methods in the social
sciences would be the perfect
springboard for a career in research and
it was I met my primary research advisor
through one of my Master's seminars that
led to a full time research position at
business school and with it an
opportunity to study under some of the
world's leading scholars in management
and organizational behavior I found
funding from my own line of research on
the moral consequences of power and
outside of my work here began to consult
on legal cases involving business
ethical issues I also spend some time
recruiting research participants for the
behavioral lab at the business school
managing and distributing datasets for
faculty and helping to teach MBA classes
these tasks weren't always in my job
description and didn't always produce an
immediate benefit to my own research
goals but they fit perfectly into my
plan to take ownership of my experience
here by helping to generate new
knowledge and sharing it with others my
time at Columbia has been deeply
enriched by all of these experiences but
I probably would not have pursued them
without the enduring influence of my
muffin lessons and so today I implore
you to take the knowledge inspiration
and relationships that you have gained
here and use them to find your passion
and to take ownership of it it can be
something small in fact sometimes the
smaller the better smaller things are
easier to make your own it doesn't
really matter what it is a research
project a book club a garden a local
playground just take ownership of
something in life in essence become its
mother give life to it breathe fresh air
into it then the most tedious and my new
task become important pieces of the
whole the spurious significance of the
extrinsic rewards fades away and the
intrinsic rewards become what drives you
and then one day pass it on make it your
legacy give a muffin lesson to someone
you love and hope that they find
fulfillment in taking ownership of
something too now before I let you get
on with the festivities of the day
please allow me to offer my gray
attitude to all who helped me get here
today first thank you to my fellow
students for helping me share the joy of
learning that you have and for
occasionally being my research guinea
pigs thank you to my teachers and
advisors particularly my research
advisors in the management division at
the business school and to dr.
Christopher Weiss and the staff of the Q
MSS program for being so generous with
your wisdom time and patience thank you
to the advanced consortium on
cooperation conflict and complexity at
the Earth Institute for your generous
funding of my master's thesis research
and most importantly thank you to my
family to my mom and dad whose muffin
lessons and countless other acts of love
and support helped me get to this point
in my life and to my brother Shawn and
to my wife Jean who amazed me with their
love inspiration and guidance every day
thank you again happy Mother's Day and
congratulations the class of 2012
Thank You mr. McGee now I would like to
present the dean's award for
distinguished achievement who masters
alumnus of the Graduate School of Arts
and Sciences to mr. Paul Auster
the Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
holds in highest regard literary
endeavor that combines intellectual
rigor and formal innovation today we
honor you for Auster an alumnus of the
graduate school whose body of work
transcends disciplinary informal
boundaries yet is characterized by your
unmistakable style a native of New
Jersey you first came to Columbia as an
undergraduate graduating from Columbia
College in 1969 and proceeding to earn
your MA in English and comparative
literature in 1970 he embarked upon a
career as a poet and translator before
publishing the memoir the invention of
solitude you then turned to fiction
writing the three books that comprised
in New York trilogy writing the three
books are comprised in New York trilogy
city of glass ghosts and the locked room
in a New York trilogy you transform the
detective novel into a meditation on
language and identity a brilliant
conceit that honors and reinvigorate the
conventions of the genre while extending
beyond them to powerful effect your
subsequent ever displays a similar
formal and conceptual ingenuity and has
been recognized throughout the world
with some of literature's highest honors
in addition to your prolific work as a
novelist he have found success in cinema
writing and directing the film's Lulu on
the bridge and the inner life of Martin
frost as well as co-writing and
co-directing blue in the face a sequel
to the film smoke for which you receive
the Independent Spirit Awards award for
best first screenplay you're one of
literature's most vivid chroniclers of
New York yet your work also has a global
resonance through your critical essays
and as an editor of the Random House
book of 20th century french poetry you
have played an instrumental role in
introducing contemporary French
literature to the American public you
have also served as an impassioned
advocate for the freedom to write and
publish both as vice president of the
pan-american center and independently in
recognition of your exceptional career
and for being a model of what a Columbia
graduate student can occur
lish the Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences is delighted to present you
Paul Auster with the Dean's Award for
distinguished achievement
the Masters address will be offered by
mr. Oster thank you I had no idea I was
getting this award until a few minutes
ago I just thought I was going to give a
talk so I'm really shocked well
greetings to all of you and
congratulations everyone of you has
earned your master degree today 42 years
ago when I myself earned a masters from
this great University I somehow managed
to avoid going to the convocation and
also skipped the commencement ceremonies
as well I suppose I was afraid of being
bored by a long-winded address delivered
by an old man dressed in academic robes
now i am that old man and here i am
dressed in academic robes please forgive
me
when Dean Alonso invited me to come here
today he made it clear that I was not
being asked to give a graduation speech
rather he wanted me to talk for a little
while about what I do which is writing
books somewhat simpler tasks than just
fencing words of wisdom about your
futures but a difficult one nevertheless
not quite sure what approach to take I
have decided to take two approaches and
therefore will be reading too short
pieces today the first is talking to
strangers a general statement about this
activity called writing and the second
is an excerpt from winter journal an
autobiographical book that will be
published in August which is not a
general statement but a personal deeply
private account of a crucial turning
point in my life as a writer first then
talking to strangers I don't know why I
do what I do if I did know I probably
wouldn't feel the need to do it all I
can say and I say it was up most
certainty is that I have felt this need
since my earliest adolescence I'm
talking about writing in particular
writing as a vehicle to tell stories
imaginary stories that have never taken
place and what we call the real world
surely it is an odd way to spend your
life sitting alone in a room with a pen
in your hand hour after hour day after
day year after year struggling to put
words on pieces of paper in order to
give birth to what does not exist except
in your own head why on earth would
anyone want to do such a thing the only
answer I've ever been able to come up
with is because you have to because you
have no choice this need to make to
create to invent is no doubt a
fundamental human impulse but to what
end what purpose does art and
particularly the art of fiction
serve in what we call the real world
none that I can think of at least not in
any practical sense a book has never put
food in the stomach of a hungry child a
book has never stopped a bullet from
entering a murder victim's body a book
has never prevented a bomb from falling
on innocent civilians in the midst of
war some like to think that a keen
appreciation of art can actually make us
better people more just more moral more
sensitive more understanding perhaps
that is true in certain rare isolated
cases but let us not forget that Hitler
started out in life as an artist tyrants
and dictators read novels killers in
prison read novels and who is to say
they don't derive the same enjoyment
from books as everyone else in other
words art is useless at least when
compared say to the work of a plumber or
a doctor or a railroad engineer but as
uselessness a bad thing does the lack of
practical purpose mean that books and
paintings and string quartets are simply
a waste of our time many people think so
but I would argue that it is the very
uselessness of art that gives it its
value and that the making of art is what
distinguishes us from all other
creatures who inhabit this planet that
it is essentially what defines us as
human beings to do something for the
pure pleasure and beauty of doing it
think of the effort involved the long
hours of practice and discipline
required to become an accomplished
pianist or dancer all the suffering and
hard work all the sacrifices in order to
achieve something that is utterly add
magnificently useless fiction however
exists in a somewhat different realm
from the other arts it's medium is
language and language is something we
share with others
that is common to us all from the moment
we learned to talk we begin to develop a
hunger for stories those of us who can
remember our childhoods will recall how
ardently we relish the moment of the
bedtime story when our mother or father
would sit down beside us in the semi
dark and read from a book of fairytales
those of us who are parents will have no
trouble conjuring up the rapt attention
in the eyes of our children when we read
to them why this intense desire to
listen fairy tales are often cruel and
violent featuring the headings
cannibalism grotesque transformations
and evil enchantments one would think
this material would be too frightening
for a young child but what these stories
allow the child chooses to experience is
precisely an encounter with his own
fears and inner torments and a perfectly
safe and protected environment such is
the magic of stories they might drag us
down to the depths of hell but in the
end they are harmless we go we grow
older but we do not change we become
more sophisticated but at bottom we
continue to resemble our young selves
eager to listen to the next story and
the next and the next four years in
every country of the Western world
article after article has been published
bemoaning the fact that fewer and fewer
people are reading books that we have
entered what has some have called the
post literate age that may well be true
but at the same time this is not
diminished the universal craving for
stories novels are not the only source
after all films and television and even
comic books are churning out vast
quantities of fictional narratives and
the public continues to swallow them up
with great passion that is because human
beings need stories they need them
almost as desperately as they need food
and however the stories might be
presented whether on a printed page or
on the television screen
it would be impossible to imagine life
without them still when it comes to the
state of the novel to the future of the
novel I feel rather optimistic numbers
don't count where books are concerned
for there is only one reader each and
every time only one reader that explains
the particular power of the novel and
why in my opinion it will never die as a
form every novel is an equal
collaboration between the writer and the
reader and it is the only place in the
world where two strangers can meet on
terms of absolute intimacy I've spent my
life in conversations with people I've
never seen with people I will never know
and I hope to continue until the day I
stop breathing it's the only job I have
ever wanted okay now to the next piece
the excerpt from winter journal this
book is written in the second person so
that the U is in fact I the dancers
saved you they are the ones who brought
you back to life that evening in
December 1978 who made it possible for
you to experience the scalding epiphanic
moment of clarity that pushed you
through a crack in the universe and
allowed you to begin again bodies in
motion bodies and space bodies leaping
and twisting through empty unimpeded air
eight dancers in a high school gym in
Manhattan for men and for women all of
them young eight dancers in their early
20s and you sitting in the bleachers
with a dozen or so acquaintances of the
choreographers to watch an open
rehearsal of her new piece you had been
invited by David Reed a painter you met
on a student ship that took you to
Europe in 1965 now your oldest friend in
New York would ask you to come because
he was romantically involved with the
choreographer nina w a woman who did not
know
well and whose affair with David did not
last long but if you are not distorting
the facts you believe she had started
out as a dancer and Merce Cunningham's
troupe now that she had turned her
energies to choreography her work bore
some resemblance the Cunningham's
muscular spontaneous unpredictable it
was the darkest moment of your life you
were 31 years old your first marriage
had just cracked apart you had an 18
month old son and no regular job no
money to speak of grinding out your
meager inadequate living as a freelance
translator author of three small books
of poetry with at most 100 readers in
the world padding here at pittance of an
income by writing critical pieces for
Harper's the new york review of books
and other magazines and apart from a
pseudonymous detective novel you had
written the previous summer an effort to
generate some cash which still had no
publisher your work had staggered to a
halt you were stuck and confused you
would not written a poem in more than a
year and you were slowly coming to the
realization that you would never be able
to write again such was the spot you're
in that winter evening more than 32
years ago when he walked into the high
school gym to watch the open rehearsal
of Nina w's work in progress you knew
nothing about dance still know nothing
about dance but you have always
responded to it with a soaring inner
happiness whenever you see it done well
and as you took your seat next to David
you had no idea what to expect since at
that point in at w's work was unknown to
you she stood on the gym floor and
explained to the tiny audience that the
rehearsal would be divided into two
alternating parts demonstrations of the
principal movements of the piece by the
dancers and verbal commentary from her
then she stepped aside and the dancers
began to move around the floor the first
thing that struck you was that there was
no musical accompaniment the possibility
had never occurred to you dancing to
silence rather than to music for music
had always seemed
to dance inseparable from dance not only
because it sets the rhythm and speed of
the performance but because it
establishes an emotional tone for the
spectator giving a narrative coherence
what would otherwise be entirely
abstract but in this case the dancers
bodies were responsible for establishing
the rhythm and tone of the piece and
once you began to settle into it you
found the absence of music holy
invigorating since the dancers were
hearing the music in their heads the
rhythms in their heads hearing what
could not be heard and because these
eight young people were good dancers in
fact excellent dancers it wasn't long
before you began to hear those rhythms
in your head as well no sounds then
except the sounds of bare feet thumping
against the wooden floor of the gym you
can't remember the details of their
movements but in your mind you see
jumping and spinning falling and sliding
arms waving and arms dropping to the
floor legs kicking out and running
forward bodies touching and then not
touching and you were impressed by the
grace and athleticism of the dancers the
mere sight of their bodies in motion
seem to be carrying you to some
unexplored place within yourself and
little by little you felt something lift
inside you felt joy rising through your
body and up into your head a physical
joy that was also of the mind a mounting
joy that spread and continued to spread
through every part of you then after six
or seven minutes the dancers stopped
Nina w stepped forward to explain to the
audience what they had just witnessed
and the more she talked the more
earnestly and passionately she tried to
articulate the movements and patterns of
the dance the less you understood what
she was saying it wasn't because she was
using technical terms that were
unfamiliar to you it was the more
fundamental fact that her words were
utterly useless inadequate to the task
of describing the wordless performance
you had just seen for no words could
convey the fullness and brute
akala t of what the dancers had done
then she stepped aside and the dancers
began to move again immediately filling
you with the same joy who had felt
before they'd stopped five or six
minutes later they stopped again and
once more nina w came forward to speak
again failing to capture a hundredth
part of the beauty you had just seen and
back at fourth it went for the next hour
the dancers taking turns with a
choreographer bodies in motion followed
by words beauty followed by meaningless
noise joy followed by boredom and at a
certain point something began to open up
inside you you found yourself falling
through the rift between world and word
the chasm that divides human life from
our capacity to understand or express
the truth of human life and for reasons
that still confound you this sudden fall
through the empty unbounded air filled
you with a sensation of freedom and
happiness and by the time the
performance was over you were no longer
blocked no longer burdened by the doubts
that had been weighing down on you for
the past year you return to your house
and Dutchess County to the downstairs
worker room where you'd been sleeping
since the end of your marriage and the
next day you began to write for three
weeks you worked on a text of no
definable genre neither a poem or a
prose narrative attempting to describe
what you had seen and felt as you'd
watch the dancers dance and the
choreographer talk in that high school
gym in Manhattan writing many pages to
begin with and then boiling them down to
eight pages the first work of your
second incarnation of a writer the
bridge to everything you have written in
the years since that's it thank you all
for listening to me
thank you Miss roster we now arrive at
the central point of the ceremony the
presentation of the masters candidates
we ask you to come forth as we call your
name in recognition of your individual
accomplishments teen Darris birch will
read the names of the ma candidates as
they approach the podium
african-american studies Joel Phillip
baumgart naveed for Nia Tanya bolongo
bear Mariana Shepherd Lauren Jessica
Amsterdam melissa sue Walker
anthropology Dina's Abady
Tanya kaylani Leticia saatchi bermudez
juan carlos mazariegos Dina Omar Bruce
nedergaard burnside Shruti banerji
Elysia Pauline vasilis Jesse Bryce wild
our history and archaeology jessica rose
Garrett Carol Berggren Santo Larry
Caitlyn Marie Richardson Lauren Michelle
turkey Oh Catherine a cold least chemlee
leonela sir das Sarah Charo B al alawi
mitra elahi pana biological sciences
ashley rae Paulson biomedical
informatics soon Jung Jung Min whale you
touch deep singh bajwa priyanka pathak
Mary Regina Boland Maria Elena Carlo
unda jonathan kim biotechnology Diego
Rojas honor de Santiago Torrio serene
devatha Kumar k Xu Chen shun to Winston
li xiao lu xiao yue li mo nica Sophia de
estado lee hyo-jung Ned ammo fraud
Brittany Jake Perry
michael andrew res lynskey eric paul
Greenwald ran alina guru Raj pile chain
Monte vasistha when do crawl seaway song
Jung Hwan Veronica Castro sarah nick
Madalena angelica allegretto climate and
society deborah burner juan carlos 20
basil dr. Emmanuel Kenneth Allen
Sinclair Sophia Carolina villarreal more
on Troy James Simpson you xiangzhou Lynn
will you luncheon jo-lynn wang xuan's
early in good Garcia solera Gustavo
valdivia Corrales Gary Monette Stephen
Theodore so lucky Jessica naifi Sara
Blakely Melissa Matlock Vivian derson
lauren nicole smith
club guy voy show you Lynn Matthias
fluff Jerry now ileana Cardenas Trujillo
Jonathan mcgillivray we she Gloria
Christina recalled a Coronel Sarah
fackler Riddick gosh Roy Takuya yoshida
Margaret see Sutton Daniel John Souza
Nicholas Hudson Jung Hwan alexa j rohini
kamal Emily Colin just Simmons emily
louise schnarr classics Cynthia f called
her i say a cross on robbery Edith think
t 0 McGraw Webster conservation biology
Aaron penny Mulcahy Annie Margaret Dean
Katherine Anne freund Justine Whaley
Francine Stacy Johnson
michael butler brown Neelu far bhayani
Tatiana Escobar Fidel Timothy Joseph
Aegon joel robert peterson Trevor
starrin Granger Derek Jonathan Burroughs
Evan Evan Merle McCartney Mel stud east
asia regional studies benjamin dollars
arterburn parsival sola alvarado
Francisco Jose kata vide David Michael
liebenberg young Jin Yan Zhao Yun Chao
does Gabriel cigarette
John Lyman leisure row cheat on Owen
Austin Cooney Jeffrey Wayne we found
during Cole joanita jeong jo mingwei
wang one wen wang xi chen Adrian Robert
Gabriel stole off Allison Elizabeth
Bernard East Asian languages and
cultures anastasya Thomas or a paratha
Adina Yoon Jessica Naomi Goldberg steven
alexander ottinger yorkie Yahweh Tom
Tenzin dunker Kelly Midori mccormack
julie and magdalena cab lenska Laura
Catherine Warren Mickey you jung hyun
economics Daniel vr
english and comparative literature Eric
Louie mazal Laura Beverly driver Matthew
Joseph Margie knee Sebastian mumtaz e
victoria and Maury Caitlin anuria
McCartney Alicia nut Carney Tara
Carberry Aaron Maxwell Pendleton French
cultural studies in a global context
Jennifer Maria Steiner aaron lee Stein
Allison ass to know Amanda grace Sobotka
Alexandra lobby O'Neill Jessica Davison
Melanie Sharon Langer human rights
marina adoption krista jain temple Jody
ancona fee
Matthew kennis Louie Anthony Molina
human rights it says here Jillian Carson
bilder Mickelson for a week Yoshi Nene
owe me rupasinghe Stephanie Leah bloom
alexander james Dana dragana Cohen
Colleen bridgeport Donna Michelle
barakat Teresa Kasumi kretzmann
Elizabeth see Marcus yes mean Sabah
askari tamatar almalik Mary and Joseph
Linnell jorge luis escobedo Melinda mr.
Marshall international and world history
jean-louis Dawson Italian Maria Sophia
still Oh Cristina marine chiappa Alexa
Victoria elemaki Kennedy Lorenzo Filippo
bikini
japanese pedagogy rico kobayashi norica
murata now cursory all sony tochi nobuko
one guard Latin American and Iberian
studies Joanna Morales suzana ynez Perez
Julie wolf Catherine Hampton Liana
Kelsey jaikishan Mila burns nah she
meant oh excuse Nadine rom Haaretz
regional studies american studies david
paul Briand yasin vel'koz means
Christina Hyun me Kim Elizabeth Coughlin
Anna Lorena an imperial leave on Nicole
Rojas Beth Butler Liberal Studies East
Asian Studies duo Chen Jing Chou Danny
Joe Joe and rudely
Zawya Diane Sutton tell yes and target
ah Thomas ha Kyung Kim Hyun Jin Kim John
Paul deSario Nicholas Jordan Chen
Liberal Studies islamic studies hey
young Joe Sophia Ibrahim Vsauce a Nepali
Laila el khatib Julie Dawson Jewish
Studies Liberal Studies modern European
studies Miriam Annabelle ray Liberal
Studies South Asian Studies Prashant's
David Coogan oven
mathematics of Finance he Bo Young Joo
Jung Jung Bing you June we shall ming
hao li chuncheng you Bolin tongue
Clement Chan kan in a way Koshiro oh no
undress Jaime as he killed some Bolly
Oni Sebastian imel's baby and grime on
walking tapia macias Joanne Chan Sophia
Cordero Ramirez luis alberto romero
ibarra japan change wei wang yu zhou yi
anita bazinga Shima Suraj Kumar keshri
praveen Kali suave ooh young brown cow
seeming one tie white walk you john chen
khong wrong
you shooting wang xu shi jia jie anna
circle over joohyuk's I nikhil jain
Greta johanna via rosa rajashekar
Isabella Bonet Greg re bharathi Andre
lesson of ski Victor yogi on papa
Nathaniel done Roy araf re Deborah
Lelouch Miriam Melani one who knew
Alexandra Christina riederer Stefan boo
hana eduarda bear me Paul a beach ball
Kirsty Smith Victor listen
Cyril Danny Louie ratones mark vianney
Leah yah red Suzanne marine Mullen your
van nurses jean-philippe Fergus jelly
metalist rest Nicholas stretch in scheme
1 wrong the vet men on Liberal Studies
Medieval Studies Charles Christopher
Yost Jeffrey Crandall bury it seems like
deeksha da ba Ronnie dryer Middle East
South Asian and African Studies Fatima
Romani Peter Christopher subbaraj firm
Angelo whooo dilyara Elisheva modern art
critical and curatorial studies Jamie
Beth Schwartz Lisa Williams Jayron
airdam Kerry Lee Gartner era Christina a
German
Susan funder Carlson Carolyn blank and
bechler Joseph gurgle catharina and
Crawford Clausius music oral history
Jeffrey H Brodsky Shanna Marie Farrell
Chris in La Follette kathryn morris sue
night teste philosophy o Shah Nathan
physics ciao ciao political science
Ramona to Harry Amanda macadam
personally stephen daniel ration felipe
alejandra osorio Wang Mary Martha
Ferrari Douglas adam hamilton hyams
Anika milena Brooks omar farooq el octa
samee Lee Benjamin Andrew Shipman chong
hotly jun lung alchun long Ian went on
Valerie sinyun cao lu shuan michelle
sara lee when soon
Jin Wei Yao dong Joon Lee psychology
Barbra Jean well sir Meza Joanie Joan
wrong q haces quantitative methods in
the social sciences marina a cow's
Bradman Monica Eileen pereira Clara Leah
magram Joel Daniel Myers Gandalf
Hernandez John Martin Richardson
ulladulla po phikeia junkie on Clarence
tan jason sklar Vanessa moreira
Parkinson de Castro Jose cabezas Seth
Michael cresson
Frederick lungs along William long
Hennessey Kristen Bethany Kel Sarah
Sinclair bedding Warren Denise
Washington jana cova chovka alexandra
meet Vaughn Ian daniel clark petrol
Husseini Avila Audrey eres James McGee
Rihanna nicole miller Vasquez blood
Douglas leap you it nicole l williams
char Sieu chaudhary ming junk Juan Aaron
Charles Hornstein each our fun minghii
yong sheng jie shu ranch enka who's a
song with three quarters done
Russia Eurasia and East Europe regional
studies Catherine and Brooks Abigail
judge crap Sarah Mariah van wetering
Virginia and Wilkinson sociology how'd
in when Joe been so um knee a new Sri
das gupta christine tran Sonia Mendoza
kareena cat Samuels Laurel and menlo
Kevin Loughran ekaterina paul thurrott
chet lien bruh touchy
statistics jingyan lend yong sheng wang
mention wang xiao xiao yao wei hua Jiao
Jin Jin Yoo Jin Han Yi Ahn yet shall you
eg upon young bo Chang shun you Ming Zi
her Arab in kollam am Raja Peter
Benjamin Engel
fujian econo 'then Daniel jin-woo kim
jin young men zou lu lu wang qian qian
Susan way son gen Fang whoo when bosun
when ye to do by one gwenlyn yuen yuen
Xu Jun Chuo Yao Ming real jo ujong Shang
Wu chuan Gao je mao zedong fun jang when
Fang yu Xiao Tian me Bing by r
imageenable and kya catherine marie
fenya Silas marez Jonathan Rafael fancy
Shawn qu dark F by show lu wang yi fun
fun fun Jia Ming Fong
gay song waif and tong shi tao zhang li
li manly youch in dying Chow Yun nan
Jung Hyung je yo traje in feng shi wang
yan wang fun chen ying wang yang Ling
jia jia ting ting Lin you shin jung yong
Lin Wu yuen tsuen wan mei li they fail
you Rachel young we who shinsen
see hong soo-hyun john chen kid ho young
union park Fran week whoa glu minghao
GLA who we Jung theater I mirror fine
aru negara know a mean and I
dale Tirzah presses into the gsas Alumni
Board will now speak to you about the
Alumni Association of the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences istersen
thank you I'll be brief Dean Alonso
Provost cotesworth vice president Dirk's
distinguished faculty alumni friends and
our most honored participants here this
afternoon our graduates thank you for
giving me a few minutes to address you
on behalf of the Alumni Association of
the Graduate School of Arts and Sciences
and its board as board of directors as
well as the nearly 40,000 gsas alumni
worldwide I offer our graduates here
hearty congratulations on this momentous
occasion and milestone in your career I
also welcome you to the next phase of
your relationship with the Graduate
School in the university that is as
newly minted automatic members of the
gsas Alumni Association so you thought
you were finished you're not our alumni
association was formed over 50 years ago
its mission is relatively simple that is
to establish a nurturer community of
alumni foster the engagement of alumni
with the academic and institutional
initiatives of the graduate school
support the interests and needs of
current graduate students and assist the
Dean in perpetuating and enhancing the
reputation and prestige of gsas in
furtherance of our mission our board and
its various committees meet several
times a year and we have had we have
held rather well attended annual
meetings here on campus at which we have
showcased interesting and provocative
faculty speakers alumni and graduate
students who have been very willing to
share their work we are particularly
committed group of alumni who pride
ourselves on having some fun together
along with our fearless leader Dean
Alonso we also have food and wine so
that's a big draw
we have sponsored a variety of events
including career panels and alumni
socials and many of us have mentored
students as they look forward to careers
including those outside the academic
world we have also helped publicize and
support graduate school activities such
as departmental reunions concerts
lectures and the like and of course we
work with and support the activities of
the overarching columbia alumni
association of which you are also newly
minted members we have hosted and
sponsored events in New York Washington
Chicago Los Angeles and San Francisco
among other cities we even spent a few a
weekend a few years ago at biosphere 2
an Oracle in Oracle where we spend some
time with some aunts and I along with
other board members have met with gsas
alums around the world in London Paris
Geneva beijing in Hong Kong so wherever
you are we can find you but how do we
keep in touch through various ways
including mailings the gsas alumni
newsletter called superscript and
generally via our gsas alumni website we
have one gsas columbia.edu backslash
alumni many of us also follow graduate
school activities by a logging on to the
newsletter for gsas students with which
I'm sure you're familiar it's called 109
low but our success depends in large
part on you our newest fellow alums
first we need to know how to be in touch
with you so your correct email address
and physical address are important and
we want to hear from you we want you to
contribute to our newsletter if not
articles feel free to share
announcements of publications and
professional achievements give us your
ideas on how we can further our mission
come to events be in touch get involved
and if you don't heed my advice and you
become a rather sleepy alum here comes a
voluntary disclosure from a lawyer I was
a rather sleepy alum for 20 years and if
somebody from gsas
comes knocking on your door like they
did mine and let you know how much
you've been missing at your number one
alma mater you may just find yourself as
the next president of the gsas Alumni
Association giving a welcome addition
thank you congratulations again and
welcome to the Alumni Association Thank
You mr. sir and now my closed closing
remarks to the graduating class we are
engaged today in one of the most solemn
moments of academic life in a grand
setting surrounded by those dearest to
us yet I would encourage you to examine
it for the ritual that it is with its
trappings customs and the very very
silly hats some of you may ask
rightfully whether there are times in
which it would be best to suspend
critical scrutiny and bask unabashedly
in the joy of the moment life can life
is continually presenting us with such
moments of unadulterated bliss or sorrow
for that matter finding love the birth
of a child the death of someone dear to
us and it behooves us to give ourselves
totally to these moments if we're going
to have a claim to being fully alive but
this is precisely the solace and the
comfort that you have waived even in the
relatively short apprenticeship that has
taken you to this afternoon because
regardless of the discipline in which
you will receive your master's degree
this coming Wednesday what you have
learned is not merely a way of asking
questions about particular objects but
the very discipline of asking questions
itself hence you should be proud of and
faithful to what you have learned here
but the discipline of asking questions
requires that you not be so proud and so
faithful that you be unable to critique
the very education that you have
acquired in this institution in order to
be continually open to the new you must
be able to take your distance from the
presumed necessity of what you have
learned here
to challenge the very things that define
you as belonging to your institutional
origin to entertain at every turn the
possibility of self-imposed exile from
your academic home we must train
ourselves to think outside those
confines not just because knowledge is
increasingly multi and interdisciplinary
interdisciplinary but because above all
what we aim to teach you was the
acquisition of the vexing habit of
continually challenging everything you
espouse the kind of openness to the new
that I proposed and the vigilance
required for it maintained itself in
your scholarly life will be learned
every single day in a negotiation of all
the experiences with which life will
present you all the daily moments in
which your capacity to confront change
or to become the agent of change will be
tested not only or even principally by
what is new and unforeseen but even more
forcefully and dangerously by what is
customary and what will be expected of
you it will be at such moments that you
will renew the legitimacy of this agree
that you're about to receive and the
trust that this institution will deposit
in you by granting it at such moments it
will be worth remembering that you will
not confer this agree just because you
could ask certain questions but also so
you would ask questions critically
doggedly and unsparingly even if perhaps
especially if the one not spared is
yourself we are in verse nowadays in a
radical technological turning point that
whether we agree with it or not has
already changed thoroughly who and what
we are how we do our work and even how
we read the symptoms of this new
circumstance whether related to the
commodification of all experience that
characterizes globalization or to what
may seem to us as as the narcissism of
the digital social networks or to the
transformation of reading into a sort of
skimming they are however not a passing
phenomenon
they're here to stay and no amount of
railing against them will change that
fact in the face of that reality we must
first be honest with ourselves and
further and most especially be generous
with our students who do not even have
the experience of another way of being
and sees expressing disappointment about
the deficiencies and limitations of
their novel ways of knowing our students
no other things possess different skills
and make other kinds of connections with
the information that they possess and
with the world this openness to the new
as represented by our students
performance of their cells is going to
be I think the single most substantial
challenge as scholars and pedagogues
that we will all be facing in the near
future the humanistic Shibboleth an
unexamined life is not worth living may
not be relevant anymore when when one's
life is minutely excruciating Lee and
routinely displayed for conspicuous
examination in Facebook Twitter and
Vimeo it may very well be that we will
have to contend with a new understanding
of the self not based on concepts and
metaphors of depth and uniqueness one
that will be articulated not in a
vertical but in a horizontal
understanding of the subject such a
transformation will have a profound will
have profound implications for ourselves
for our students and for the ways in
which we will understand our
professional work henceforth but most
important you will have to come to terms
with these issues using the critical and
intellectual tools that you have
acquired in this institution and take
them to their ultimate consequences even
if the kind of scholar that you were
trained to be or that you thought you
would be may no longer be tenable as
propositions for the gift that your
Columbia graduate education has given
you is to be able to entertain in your
mind the most radical thought experiment
what if things were otherwise than what
they are what if you were not
how do you think you are and then to
reimagine the world anew we your
professors and mentors in the Graduate
School of Arts and Sciences are certain
that you will take meticulous care of
this exacting gift of the cultivation of
the otherwise go forth prosper and
prevail make us and your relatives and
friends proud it's prouder still of you
than we are today well the candidates
all stand so we may give them a final
round of applause please